mike has mentioned previously ben has
played with limited or no practice reps
in the past what can you learn from
those experiences that could potentially
help you this week as you prepare for
the bengals
you know i'm not overly concerned about
it this guy's been doing his job for 17
years he's got snap experience that he
can call upon
we're still going to work extremely hard
virtually
to prepare
a lot of his work is above the neck
anyway
in terms of preparation i have very
little concern about it to be quite
honest with you
mike tomlin steelers coach regarding the
fact that ben roethlisberger is on the
covet 19 reserve list we mentioned that
briefly in the first segment sitting
next to vance mcdonald on the flight
home from dallas close enough contact to
get roethlisberger excluded from the
facility and in isolation for five days
even if he never tests positive even if
he never has a single symptom even if
he's perfectly fine he is away from the
team just like matthew stafford was for
the lions last week so now you have to
get ready without practice it's unclear
how much he would have practiced anyway
to his knees not one knee both knees so
uh yeah they got to get them ready
without practicing them practice on
wednesdays anyway every single week he
didn't practice because of veteran rest
day
so he's practicing thursdays and fridays
and tomlin's right at this point how
much practice does he really need
here's a question here's a question
shireen williams raised yesterday that i
need to explore with the steelers
how does his treatment for his knees
work if he's in isolation that's a good
one that's a good one i i wonder how
that does work now
you know some of the stuff he's doing
like the machines things like that i
know i've gone through it before they
probably could bring those to his house
maybe his wife goes to the facility and
gets a few of the you know big leg
sleeves that push this really cold water
in there and then they it moves around
with pressure to push the swelling out
and everything like that and then i
think they probably have to end up doing
zoom exercises i guess that would be how
i would think it has to go down
something like that they can they can
manage it they could pull it off
and you know mike tomlin like you said
it he's right i mean big ben at this
point of his career it is just about
getting the mechanics of okay we're
running this oh i gotta check to this
when they play that defense all but yeah
you want to practice
but man if there's a handful of guys in
football that can get away with no
practice
uh he would be on that short list of
guys certainly to where i wouldn't worry
too much this guy has been
able to deal with these type of things
his whole career i mean we talk about it
all the time how beat up he played in
the prime of his career and he had a lot
of weeks back then where he couldn't
practice and do things um but
the big thing is
and to what you said
bengals are scary
they are scary
and i think they match up somewhat well
with pittsburgh who we saw didn't play
their best football i want to see how
they bounced back this week but with
that past defense joe burrow's ability
to get the baud of his hands quickly
pittsburgh's past defense is good i'm
not trying to say that but they're not a
man-to-man lock you down type team and
joe burrows ability to read defenses and
get the ball out and they call a lot of
short quick passes and they're talented
at receiver
uh i could see them hanging in there and
making this game very interesting i
wouldn't be shocked by that at all
i mean really even though the steelers
are eight no for the first time in
franchise history they've only played
their best football once this year
against the browns where they were on
both sides of the ball right every other
game was flawed in some way at least one
of the games they should have lost that
was the ravens game there are other
games where you know they're just living
too close to the edge here and it feels
like at some point they're going to get
that one l to go with however many wins
they pile up
mike tomlin also said that the steelers
followed the nfl's policy in letting
vance mcdonald play you alluded to this
last segment apparently he wasn't
feeling well on friday but he still
tested negative so he was allowed to
stay with the team look i i thought that
they
had a rule that if you don't feel well
they send you home no questions asked
that's what happened to odell beckham jr
right a couple of weeks ago and see this
is when
the doctors maybe are making decisions
the doctors who are hired and paid by
the team and the doctors don't want to
take players out of the mix unless they
have to yeah
and no he's an a he's negative he
doesn't have it he's fine yeah he's not
feeling well but you know it's cold and
flu season he's got some other bug i
thought the nfl was taking the position
that if you don't feel well
we're sending you home
and we'll keep testing you and if you
still are negative then you can come
back
but uh again tomlin says they followed
the policy and maybe they did maybe the
policy needs to be tweaked a little bit
more
because clearly in this case unless it's
just a coincidence and if it is it's one
hell of a coincidence that he he that he
had the the cold or or the flu and it
was chased by covid and he he wasn't
feeling ill on friday for any reasons
relating to his eventual positive but
something's not right here there's a
doughnut hole there's multiple doughnut
holes in this process and that feels
like one what it definitely does i i
mean to me yeah the protocol has to be
changed there i mean we're seeing this
too much i mean throughout the country
forget about sports whatever it is you
know i don't feel good and then yeah
like we talked about earlier the
positive test doesn't come for a few
days for whatever reason the virus takes
a few days 48 hours whatever it is to
ruminate in the body and come out of the
positive test that way so i mean i would
think at some point here because of this
specifically
that okay you don't feel well we send
you home
and yeah we test you every day but you
don't get to come back no matter what
until that third day or that fourth day
doesn't matter you didn't feel good we
can't take the chance we don't know we
don't want you sitting on the plane with
our two biggest superstars on our team
or the big the starting quarterback or
whatever i would think that would make
sense to adjust that part of the policy
for sure yeah even then if there was any
chance that vance mcdonald had it
because he wasn't feeling well i would
put him at the back end of the plane and
i would put ben in the front row and all
your other key players lock them in the
bathroom donald as possible absolutely
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports